hi I'm Callie plaguey reading this
review of dynasty Warriors 9 for
freelancer James Swain banks dynasty
Warriors 9 represents the biggest shift
away from the series established formula
since moving from a one-on-one fighting
game to its more established Musso form
while the feeling of cutting down entire
formations of soldiers the button press
will feel more than familiar to fans of
the series the introduction of a massive
open world changes the pacing in a way
that allows the action to breathe and
although it suffers from a number of
disappointing technical hitches along
with some typical open-world jenk
dynasty Warriors 9 sprawling campaign
feels right at home in its new setting
given that its story mode is presented
unconventionally it can take a little
while to figure out precisely what's
going on the entire story of the Three
Kingdoms of China is told through the
eyes of over 80 separate playable
characters across four major clans way
wushu and Jin's as well as a handful of
other smaller bit players playing
through each chapter unlocks the next
one along with more characters seeing
each battle from multiple perspectives
is enthralling from a historical point
of view but it can mean playing through
a lot of the same missions multiple
times which can be a little frustrating
given there is little difference in the
feel of any given character out on the
battlefield the open world is the big
game changer here and in so many ways it
works to the game's advantage missions
are picked up from NPCs out in the world
and among the different cities that dot
the landscape instead of out of a menu
although the menu option is still there
if you want to merely move from mission
to Mission traveling from one area to
the other gives you a chance to find
peaceful moments in between each battle
your actions in the open world are also
tied closely to each main quest
completing sub quests will lower the
recommended character level of the main
quest so if you find a mission too
difficult you can polish off a few sub
quests and lower its difficulty if you
make your way off-road when moving
towards the frontlines the chances are
good that you'll find a dangerous group
of bandits to take down or a pack of
wild deer or Tigers to hunt although
many of the optional open-world
activities like hunting or fishing
aren't especially inspiring in
themselves they net you aleut you can
trade for valuable goods or using
to buff your attacking defense the world
is massive and in its own way quite
pretty its sparsity reflects the period
and the vast and varied environments
flows seamlessly into one another the
day/night and full weather cycles aren't
just visual changes but also affect the
action soldiers won't March at nighttime
and bad weather will slow them down but
overall it also just looks plain grimy
at times many of the game's textures
appear as though they've been lathered
in a thick coat of Vaseline cities and
palaces suffer from this the most as
their elaborate architecture often fails
to load with high-res textures at first
leaving them looking like big brown
lumps in the world instead of beautiful
ancient Chinese palaces
aside from randomly appearing geometry
the graphical shortcomings are perhaps
most noticeable in the character
costumes while character models and
costume designs themselves are
absolutely stunning the textures within
them lack the sort of clarity needed to
work up close this combined with rough
animations and some truly abysmal
English voice-over work make sure you
switch to the Chinese voice over
immediately make the story cutscenes a
little tough to look at given the
frequency with which they're shown the
volunteer forces are to assist the
Imperial Army do not try and be a hero
given the game's technical issues it's a
good thing that cutting down thousands
of men in a single setting feels as
satisfying as ever entire squadrons can
be laid to waste in mere moments it's
truly an epic power fantasy that even
after 50 hours of gameplay continues to
thrill while the bow as well as
horseback combat can be underwhelming
the melee combat remains the biggest
draw and the series strongest pillar it
does lack a certain subtle nuance in
some of the later one-on-one boss
battles but nine times out of ten you'll
come out of battle with a smile on your
face
it's clear that Co a tecmo and Omega
Force have gone back to the drawing
board with dynasty Warriors 9 and in
many ways it's a big improvement on the
series mainstays the new open-world
format changes up the game in a way that
helps the flow and pacing of story mode
as well as its core mechanics sure there
are obvious graphical flaws and some
more subtle issues with combat locking
finer controls the streamlining of
countless menus of previous games into
an open world and the laughably fun
moment-to-moment play makes dynasty
Warriors 9 not just a must for fans but
worth a look for them merely curious